[Musique]
bonjour à chacune et chacun d'entre vous
alors comme vous le savez peut-être la
convivialité fait aussi partie de l'ADN
du Mouvement Démocrate aussi pour les 24
25 et 26 novembre nous vous convions un
second temps de cialité qui aura lieu
partout en France au sein de nos
différents mouvements départementaux que
vous soyez simples citoyens que vous
soyez force sov de la nation que vous
soyez élu nous vous convions donc à
venir partager tous ensemble ce moment
de convivialité euh adhérant non
adhérant sympathisant ou simplement
parce que vous vous intéressez à
l'actualité du Mouvement Démocrate
n'hésitez pas à prendre contact avec nos
responsables départementaux pour venir à
notre rencontre partout en France nous
serons là pour partager ce temps
d'échange qui nous permettra notamment
de discuter des grands enjeux auxquels
notre pays est confronté aujourd'hui
alors venez échanger librement avec nous
dans la plus grande simplicité et dans
la plus grande convivialité je compte
sur
[Musique]
vous